ننوه بهذا الخبر نقلا عن كتائب القسام
انها قصفت تلبيب برشقه صاروخيه وذلك ردا
على المجازر الصهيونيه في حق المدنيين
وكنا قد ذكرنا ان صفارات الانذار تدوي
حاليا في تل ابيب ومعنا من غلاف غزه ل
يطلعنا على المزيد من التفاصيل بشان هذا
الاستهداف وال القصف لتل ابيب من جانب
كتائب القسام معنا الياس كرام تفضل
الياس بالفعل لله صافرات الانذار دوت في
مناطقه واسعه جدا ونحن في طريقنا الان من
منطقه غلاف غزه الى مدينه تلي ابيب
وصافرات الانذار دوت حقيقه ليس فقط في
مدينه تل ابيب الكبرى وضواحيها الجنوبيه
بل المناطق الجنوبيه من مدينه تل ابيب
الضواحي ضواحي الزود الضواحي الجنوبيه
لمدينه تل ابيب لست سيونا وريش لتسيون
وغيرها من المناطق تذكرنا حقيقه في اليوم
الاول للحرب اي صافرات الانذار التي دوت
في الدقائق الاخيره كانت شامله للعديد من
المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى بطبيعه الحال
بما فيها مدينه تل ابيب وضواحيها تحديدا
الشرقيه والجنوبيه منها اي هنالك ايضا في
منطقه اللد والرمله اي في المناطق الشرقيه
لمدينه تلي ابيب صافرات الانذار تدوي اذا
في عموم هذه في المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى
وهنالك انباء اوليه عن اعتراض اعتراضات
صاروخيه في سماء مدينه تلي ابيب ذاتها
الحديث الاولي هو عن عشره صواريخ كما يبدو
اطلقت باتجاه منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى وهذه
هي للمره الاولى منذ مطلع العام الجديد
بعد ان كانت مدينه تل ابيب قد قصفت بدفعه
صاروخيه في اول ايام السنم
في الواقع الياس وانت تتحدث نشاهد معك صور
الان تظهر الرشق الصاروخيه التي اطلقتها
كتائب القسام على تل ابيب وضواحيها والتي
قالت انها رد على المجازر الصهيونيه بحق
المدنيين نعم هنالك اذا ليلى عده اعتراضات
صاروخيه كما يبدو في سماء مدينه تنب اديب
وهنالك سقوط لبعض الصواريخ كما يبدو في
منطقه السهل الداخلي حيث كانت ايضا في هذه
المناطق قد دوت صافرات الانذار في مناطق
عده حقيقه في السهل الداخلي وفي مناطق تل
ابيب الكبرى وكنا ليلى قد تحدثنا هذا
اليوم عن ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ابدت في
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه قدره على اطلاق
الصواريخ في منطقه غلاف غزه حيث كانت هذه
الصافرات قد دوت في از وت وفي مناطق جنوب
عسقلان واستهدفت هذه المناطق حقيقه في
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه بدفعات صاروخيه من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكنا نتحدث صباح
هذا اليوم عن القدره التي تبديها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في تحديد المكان والزمان وهذا
اليوم ايضا في تحديد المديات للاطلاق
الصاروخيه لتثبت مره اخرى بانها ما زالت
قادره على استهداف العمق الاسرائيلي ما
زالت قادره على استهداف مدينه ابيب
الكبرى في عمر هذه الحرب بعد 15 يوما بعد
المئه من اندلاع هذه الحرب اذا نحن نتحدث
عن الان عن سقوط لاحد الصواريخ في منطقه
اللد وفي منطقه بيت دجان اذا هنالك عده
اي مناطق سقطت فيها كما يبدو صواريخ لكن
واضح بانها كانت دفعه صاروخيه كبيره دفعه
صاروخيه
من وماذا عن القبه
الحديديه يعني اعترضت بعض هذه
الصواريخ كما يبدو كذلك بالفعل لكن
التقديرات الاوليه الان تشير الى ان هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه اشتملت على 15 صاروخا
مره واحده وهذه دفعه صاروخيه كبيره لم
تحدد المصادر الاسرائيليه مكان اطلاقها
لكن من الواضح باننا نتحدث عن مدى يزيد عن
اكثر من 60 كيلومترا هذا اذا ما اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار انها اطلقت من المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه اذا نحن نتحدث عن مدى
يزيد عن 60 ك مت من السياج الامني ونتحدث
عن دفعه صاروخيه كبيره تشمل بحسب
التقديرات الاوليه عن على
15 صاروخا هذا يذكرنا ايضا في الدفعه
الصاروخيه التي اطلقت من المناطق الوسطى
قبل اسابيع عده وكانت استهدفه مدينه
نتيفوت برشقه صاروخيه كبيره وهائل كنا
شهودا عليها في وقته وكانت اشتملت بحسب
التقديرات الاسرائليه على 50 صاروخا دفعه
واحده وهذا مؤشر على ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ليلى ما زالت قادره على تحديد
زماني ومكاني ومدا هذه الاستهدافات
الصاروخ في اليوم الخام عشر بعد المئه اذا
ما زالت هذه الرشقات الصاروخيه تطلق وتصل
الى تل ابيب فقط نذكركم
بالخبر الذي اوردناه نقلا عن كتائب القسام
بانها قصفت تل ابيب برشقه صاروخيه ردا على
المجازر الصهيونيه بحق المدنيين والصور
التي تشاهدونها هي صور لهذه الرشق
الصاروخيه التي ذكر الياس انها تتالف من
15 صاروخا بمدى 60 ك م اذا افترضنا انها
اطلقت من شمال القطاع